[Reading] Most of the sediment and
nutrients of the Mississippi River
no longer reach the coastal wetlands,
a phenomenon that has adversely
affected the region's
ecological balance.[stops reading]
This feels pretty good, I'm kind of
in the mood for No Error,
but let me just double-check it.
So, 'most of the sediment and nutrients
of the Mississippi River',
so that's the subject right over here,
'no longer reach', yeah, this isn't even
up for debate, no need to underline this,
but we have Subject-Verb agreement
where we're talking about a plural,
'sediment and nutrients' and they
'no longer reach' and that makes sense,
'the coastal wetlands, a phenomenon
that has adversely affected the region's
ecological balance.' Yeah, this feels really good.
I would throw in this as a No error.